it's a great day to be alive isn't it
[Music]
good morning ladies and gentlemen i'm
guessing that some of you
you're not happy maybe you don't fit in
people make fun of you
well
i can't make you straight
but you give us this week and we might
be able to help
boys cabinet over there girls cabin over
there i use they them pronouns as in
they can't believe they're at this camp
i have zero interest in not being gay
there's no judgments in this room
sometimes always sure was invisible
i would understand it a lot more if
there was bible thumping and queer
bashing do you even believe in any of
this
come in please
do you think your parents are
disappointed in you sometimes so what do
you do you try to make yourself
special
you
become
a
today we're going to be exploring
traditional gender roles
look how long they've been doing this
it's time to play
this could get a lot worse
where's my killer
we need to get out of here
taste
just enjoy the sunshine and work on your
tan
they slash them
streaming only on peacock august 5th
you